the sheriff of ventura county and he
will discuss this further
good afternoon thank you for being here
with us today
as you know since last wednesday we've
been here at lake pairu
searching for nia rivera who was
reported missing
each day we've utilized dozens of
personnel
on watercraft and helicopters
with unmanned aerial systems
and on shore uh conducting a methodical
and comprehensive search
today our search teams have recovered a
body in the lake
based on the location where the body was
found
physical characteristics of the body she
was found in the northeast
and near the surface of the water the
body the depth of the water in that area
is between
she was found in a northeastern portion
of the lake
near the surface of the water the depth
of the water in that area
is is between 35 and 60 feet deep
and there's heavy brush and trees on the
lake bed there
as you can imagine it has been an
extremely difficult time for her family
throughout this ordeal
as fathers mothers sons and daughters
our hearts are with them and we share in
their grief
for nia's loss
several witnesses who were at the lake
that day have been identified and
interviewed by sheriff's investigators
they had seen naya's boat at different
times and in several different locations
during the window of time she was out on
the lake
those witness statements helped our
teams focus their search
in the northern and eastern portions of
the lake
we received the call at 4 38 p.m on
wednesday
rangers at lake pairu began searching
the lake immediately
our deputies arrived by 5 pm
followed by one of our helicopters and
an unmanned aircraft team
investigators and a boat crew with
divers
by early thursday morning we received
assistance from several neighboring law
enforcement agencies
nya's family has expressed their
gratitude to all those involved in the
search efforts
and we would like to thank our partner
agencies for their help in this search
effort
without their assistance we could not
have covered as large an area
as quickly as we did the following
agencies provided personnel equipment
and expertise to this complex
search effort lake pyru rangers
ventura county fire department the los
angeles county sheriff's department
the san luis obispo county sheriff's
office
the tulare county sheriff's office the
united states coast guard
forward operating base point magoo and
the california governor's office of
emergency services
we also received support from fugro
geodata services
this company completed a detailed survey
and mapping mission at the lake
just three weeks earlier in advance of
the upcoming seismic
retrofitting of the santa felicia dam at
the south end of the lake
they heard about the disappearance of
nya and offered their personnel
and equipment and expertise to help
locator
their detailed maps of the lake along
with their comprehensive knowledge of
the lake
have given a major boost to this search
effort and we thank them
for their assistance that concludes my
comments
and i am available with my team here
to answer any questions that you may
have
we do we do have spanish language
available
do you believe she was in that location
the whole time or do you believe that
she floated to the top because of
decomposition
sure we do believe she was in that area
when she went swimming
based on our conversations with her son
the information that we had from the
witnesses in the area
the search effort had been focused in
that area
as i mentioned there's heavy brush 15 to
20 feet
in height that had grown when the lake
was drier
that that was an empty canyon that
tributary into the lake itself
and so you had a lot of growth that that
sprung up there
when the lake refilled with water that
growth remained and made it
very very difficult for divers for sonar
operators and for researchers to
to search that area we did focus on that
area we had our entire
dive team scour in that area yesterday
they were not able to find her
we believe she was concealed within some
of the the
shrubbery on the floor bed of the lake
so she came to the surface yesterday
there uh is a detailed examination of
the body yet to take place
but the initial examination from the
medical examiner's office
does not reveal anything that makes us
suspect there's any sort of foul play
involved
she went for a swim with her son that's
correct
the body does not have a life jacket
there was an adult sized life jacket in
the
in the pontoon boat that she had rented
was it one of the search and rescue or
your vcs
it was it was rescuers involved with the
operation uh the individuals that
happened to find her today were
lake pairu park rangers
and what was the condition of the body
this morning when you found
the body the the condition or position
the body was floating near the surface
of the water
i don't have the the specific
information as to whether the body was
facing up or down
the body looked as though it had been in
the water for several days
i don't have that information uh
yeah i'm sorry
swimming is allowed in this lake and
uh it's it's typically um what we see at
this lake is typically watercraft
recreation
um not a whole lot of swimming but it is
allowed
it uh that's right here at the at the
pier
can you tell us anything about her
her family has been at the lake every
day holding out hope and
communicating with our investigators and
our staff
we've been in constant communication
with them we've given them information
before making it publicly available
today
yes that's right
yes
the medical examiner's trained and well
prepared to examine bodies in various
states from
from burned burning to water damage to
advanced decomposition
it does complicate things a little bit
um in this case there there's
decomposition that takes place
natural process it's actually part of
the the reason we were able to find her
today the body
fills with gas becomes more buoyant and
then surfaces
on its own so i don't anticipate
there'll be any problems
conducting a postmortem autopsy sheriff
it would be speculation to say at this
point there there are a lot of currents
on the lake that that uh appear
particularly in the afternoon
we believe it was mid afternoon when she
disappeared
the idea perhaps being that the boat
started drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself
the sun was in the water yes
we do have a spanish interpreter
there are uh there there are ladders on
the boats yes they're designed for
swimming
okay all right thank you very much
thank you everybody that concludes the
press conference um yeah we're gonna get
you taken care of
uh for spanish media uh
do you wanna do that up here or
[Music]
sorry i need to grab my legs
foreign
all right
thank you
you